and with the cardinals losing two in a
row with the rams losing yesterday to
the 49ers
between arizona and la becomes
gigantic especially because your san
francisco 49ers nipping at the heels of
the arizona cardinals fighting one game
that separates them now the cardinals
have the initial leg up in the tie
breaker but they play again week 16
cardinals and the 49ers in arizona which
may soon become the de facto home
stadium for the 49ers what a crazy
situation though but we saw this coming
all year with the pandemic the 49ers by
order in santa clara county they're
going to talk to the folks in santa
clara to say hey can we get an exception
can we get an exemption can we get a
dispensation can we get something man
santa clara says no they're going to
have to find a place to play it looks
like it's going to be arizona but the
49ers are figuring it out that was i
think
i don't know that was their biggest win
of the year because i already beat the
rams once they've swept the rams we have
been all over the rams this year the
rams are seven and four they're 0-2
against the 49ers we cannot count out
the 49ers and and with the cardinals
fading and with the bucks fading
maybe two of these teams in that in the
hunt column are going to find a way to
crash the party chris well i mean yeah
the way i mean aaron i mean we know san
francisco is getting healthy we saw you
know debo samuel richard sherman some of
those guys yesterday and you go whoa
here they go the quarterback play you
know for the first time in a while was
pretty damn solid and hey i mean the
shanahan mcveigh matchup there's a lot
of knowledge there there really is about
what they do and shanahan and robert
sala have done a great job of really
taking away mcveigh's offense and the
two meetings we saw them this year they
got it down into the game that we always
talk about oh wait the run games and the
boots aren't there is jared goff in the
drop back pass game gonna beat you i
think not more times than not i'm gonna
take that approach and the 49ers have
really figured out mcvay's offense that
way and uh it's where kyle shanahan is
amazing you know say what you want
whatever
you know the state of this team and all
the injuries and it's been we've talked
about it millions and millions and
millions of dollars on ir and the fact
that they're sitting here at five and
six and got a chance uh i think that
says a lot about the coaching staff and
especially kyle jared goff and carson
wentz for the top two picks in the 2016
draft wence has been
not good this year and i can't help but
wonder where jared goff would be without
sean mcvay and i still wonder whether or
not they regret giving goff the contract
he did every time we think
that he's earning it like last monday
night against the bucks
then there's a game where it's like
man there's a lot of guys out there that
could do this and maybe do it a lot
better than jared goff
all due respect but that nfc the look
you've got the packers you've got the
saints and beyond that
i really don't know what you've got
maybe seattle they get a chance tonight
yeah to cross the country and play the
eagles but there's a there's a lot of
grind at the bottom there's a lot of
chances and remember there's still a
possibility chris of eight teams per
conference getting in right that makes
it even more of a meat grinder in the
nfc because you're gonna have an eight
seed potentially going to play the one
seed and i think from a talent
standpoint the difference between eight
and one
is not going to be all that great so
no well hang on let's just think about
it this way we talk about the nfc east
and all that stuff right
the giants went to play the rams earlier
this year and it was a one score game
and it was there to be had so
to what you're saying it's a match-up
league and you could be better as a
bunch of teams as a whole but when it
comes to playing that particular team
you could be in big trouble and don't
match up as well and i think we're
seeing that a lot this year
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports